john mcguire
hello thanks for coming on the show hey
it's a thrill for me to be here with you
atlas
i'm so excited for this yeah i'm
grateful for adelita montero for
introducing us
she's so nice oh what a gem yeah
we had a rocking conversation on the
show together and then
right afterwards she was like john
mcguire that's who
that's who needs to come on and we had
our little face time together that was
so sweet oh yeah
yeah and then we just booked it yes
and here we are synchronicity
i know i know and kinesiology and
consciousness is going to be such a fun
episode we're going to be talking about
muscle testing
the levels of consciousness the
influence that that has
on our societal landscape on a
geopolitical and business level
which is hugely influential because it
may be
that egoic levels of consciousness that
are
in the greatest positions of power
across the planet is our most
upstream issue that we face all right
yeah and we'll have demos we're gonna
have demos with
with muscle testing that we can do at
home for the audience as well
um regarding just basic muscle testing
we also have props like things like food
to share with people which will be
really exciting
and also we have some links in the bio
below
to john's kinesiology institute if you
guys want to go and explore
he has content there for you to check
out as well
as he has a new uh digital copy
of his muscle testing book that accesses
innate intelligence
and the link's also there in the bio
below which you can email
to request that and so we'll be
unpacking all of that
john i wanna as we get into some of the
more
uh fundamentals of kinesiology and
consciousness i wanna kind of get to
know
your the journey perspective so when
you're born in akron in ohio
and then who were you growing up that
even got you
interested in kinesiology and
consciousness
well early my breakthrough came
and when i was at oberlin college and
the second semester i moved
and i was like all into rock and roll
and drugs and
like lower consciousness and and wasn't
even aware of this stuff
so i move into a natural foods co-op
because it was the cheapest place on
campus to live and i wanted to save
money and i didn't even know what
natural foods were
i was like beer and pizza was you know
my staples
okay so my roommate said hey i'm going
to a yoga class a yoga class you want to
come along is it well i don't know
and i went and that was a major shift in
my life because the
the yoga teacher um was like
tuned in to higher consciousness that i
was unaware of so
i ended up taking a meditation like
transcendental meditation
uh he he brought us to see ramadas
and so uh yeah so i got to see ramdas
and it was like
my life just totally changed wow from
beer and pizza to natural foods co-op
and yoga and ram das i love the
transition this is so great
okay keep going yeah so
so i became a vegetarian and uh
it told that just the food alone raised
my vibration
and then i was meditating i was doing
yoga
and you know my aspiration when i was a
teenager was to be a rock and roll star
right
well then it was about okay no i want to
be a vehicle for higher consciousness
so i became a yoga instructor and a
meditation instructor
in akron ohio so i was teaching around
northeastern ohio
and one of my students was a
chiropractor at the end of the class he
said hey i want to show you something
so he said hold your arm up and so so
i'm going to push on your arm and you
just meet my pressure and
see what happens and so okay and he
pushes and it tests strong
so he says now watch this so he does
something to
shift the energy flow in my acupuncture
meridians
which in yoga we know the piranha in the
body circulating one high level prada
and all of a sudden
i can't hold my arm up and he goes watch
this he he directs the energy in another
way and
my arm is totally strong so he says
we're doing this
a lecture demonstration on applied
kinesiology at my office why don't you
come and check it out
so i go see this says wow this is
fascinating you can
you can find out where there's energy
blocks in the body that are causing
health challenges
and how when you unblock that energy and
you get the
all the systems flowing in the
vibrational
frequency of the body to be elevated
your health vastly improves and symptoms
go away
naturally yes so then i said where did
you study this is oh we we learned it
from this guy named
dr george goodhart in detroit michigan
who's beautiful who discovered this i
thought wow that would be amazing to
study with him
fast forward two years later now i'm a
body worker
and i'm working in a chiropractic office
in youngstown ohio
so we go on a winter vacation to
colorado
and on the trip the chiropractors say
hey
dr anderson is going to study with
george goodhart
for a year-long certification program
do you want to go along i was like wow
just dropped right in my lap so
i became uh basically certified and
applied kinesiology in 1982.
and that totally changed my practice you
know as a massage therapist
i was using what good heart called the
rub and hope method
you know i had all these techniques but
i didn't know what technique to do i
didn't know what was
causing a person's you know challenges
so we learned you know all these ways to
massage the body and hopefully
they'd be better and often they would be
but sometimes we'd miss the boat
yeah well goodheart talked about the
triad of health
which is physical the structural body
then we have the the biochemical
and nutritional aspects of health of
course that affect
the structure yeah and then we have the
mental and emotional
side of the triad of health that affects
the other two so everything affects
everything
so then i started realizing that there's
times when people have back pain
that's due to emotional issues and good
heart call that emotional low back
wow and there's other issues like when
i've started learning this
and applying it we'd have people with
mental and emotional issues like one man
had
anxiety and insomnia his doctor
which conventional western medicine
which certainly has its place
totally absolutely has its place but
they often will
treat the symptom totally totally and
not
find the cause yeah so with this one man
when i was testing i found oh there's
structural issues
the base of the triangle and he needed
to have
cranial adjustments which were affecting
his brain which were affecting his
pineal gland
which was affecting his melatonin output
which was affecting his sleep
which was affecting his anxiety and was
affecting
you know the whole issue with uh
his health so just merely doing that
and one other correction came up
balancing his chakras
yes see the chakras affect everything
those are the energy centers in the body
that are also corresponding to nerve
plexuses
of course so when we did you know
those balances he no longer had the
anxiety
he no longer had the insomnia and i just
spoke with him the other day this is
like
probably 15 years later and he's still
doing great
so the analogy is this when you have a
puddle of water on the floor
you can get a mop and mop it up but if
the puddle comes back
you say well let me get a better mop or
let me get a different mop or let me get
a
shop vac but if you never look up at the
ceiling and see
oh there's a hole in the roof exactly
why treat the symptom
and ignore the cause so the source
is what you know good heart particularly
was able to
to help us define through muscle testing
it's a way of tapping into the body's
innate intelligence
that's right and energy systems because
we are basically all
energetic vibrational beings yes and the
muscle testing says where
is the let's say disharmony where are
the frequencies not
flowing where and the energies blocked
and when you find out where it's blocked
and which technique will
unblock it then muscle testing also
helps to show you
did your correction work and ultimately
the person feels better
almost immediately instantly yeah
wow oh
such a fascinating journey i love the
transition
at such a young age from beer to beer
and pizza
to buddha beer to buddha yeah
it's a really beautiful transition and
there's always these
these profound influences that happen to
us along our journey that
catalyze our interest to go
inward and that interest to go inward
it's a classic parable of the prodigal
son you know the more that you go
outward and outward and outward
in seeking happiness externally the more
you're going to recognize that happiness
is found
through the inward path of recognizing
that consciousness
is it that we are already it
and that that is known as the this well
of
honey of peace and bliss that is under
the rock
yeah and that we have to go inward in
order for us to dissolve that egoic
rock of the separate entity and to have
that
that well of honey be 24 7
bliss and peace and then that is
an effortless outward path that then
happens it becomes effortless to express
ourself artistically
in a way that is extremely harmonic with
the planetary intelligence that is
already
present and so i love these fundamental
moments of yours and for so many of the
other guests that have them go
inward and it was so profound like it
also obviously has
happened to me and just been so
influential
and then also i love how as you're
explaining like this perfect opportunity
that lands it was it used to be the
rub and hope method with the muscle
uh as as a masseuse and then
moving into the good heart method so
george goodheart
being a the founder of applied
kinesiology approximately you said 55
years ago or so yeah it was in 1964 he
made his first discoveries
first discoveries around then and then
you
about 20 years later in 84 right
82 in 82 82 so around yeah 18 or so
years later that you had the opportunity
to
go for a year-long course of his yes and
he has this triad
and it's fascinating because when
adanito was on the show
she also has the similar triad of course
because it is the most fundamental
way to look at it you have the physical
and then you have that
biochemical which is all about what you
put in as an
input into the body as nutrition and
all of the ayurvedic techniques as well
and then also similarly with your input
stream of content
right of of all of the modern technology
age your input stream also affects you
obviously tremendously as well on the
content
side and then you have this mental
emotional
side of things which is kind of like
your psyche and
the the consciousness or the awareness
that is kind of the home
to all of those your moment-to-moment
experiences and existence
that you're having and then adelita also
had this great
like everything is encompassed that pie
is encompassed by the spiritual
yeah and and that's another obviously
great way to look at so
this triad is so fundamental and it's so
all these different guests that we've
been having on the show around
maximizing well-being they're all doing
something they're just piecing the triad
in different ways
yeah and those are all of the different
faces up the same mountain of maximizing
our well-being
it's like the one truth at the top of
the mountain of this is how
to hone in on optimizing on maximizing
your well-being and everyone else's yeah
it's
gorgeous yeah so
it sounds like then that you took what
the teachings of george goodhart were
into your
applied kinesiology practice and then
you kind of started to
undergo this you know muscle testing is
something that
i you know david hawkins has obviously
been a massive influence on you
me adolita and beyond as well but it
seems like it's becoming
more and more popular so why don't you
keep walking us through the process
of what happened to you in the formation
also of the kinesiology institute and
moving to los
angeles to pasadena and your continued
great story well at the end of my
a certification with good heart in the
fall of 82
i took a touch for health instructor
training
to to actually teach other people touch
for health now touch for health was
started by dr
john thief from pasadena and he was one
of good hearts
they called him the dirty dozen the
first group of
about is actually about 20 different
doctors
that said let's codify dr
goodhart's work and put it into a system
that we can teach others
well john thief said to goodheart why
don't we teach this to lay people
and write a book for them and goodheart
was so busy with the latest research he
said john if you want a book for lay
people you write it
so he wrote the book touch for health
that could bring it to the masses
and it was such a brilliant thing that's
really made such a difference
because then not just the licensed
doctor
but the general population and
paraprofessionals
could start using muscle testing and all
this knowledge this bottle
body of knowledge of how to bring the
body into balance
energetically and we use again muscle
testing to find out what's bringing it
out of balance which will demonstrate
here today how you can test the foods
you eat
you can even test things like lifestyle
as you you know with
the book power versus force with david
hawkins work
you can test just about everything in
including
uh you know businesses and uh
pathways of your life you know like if
someone's saying well i've done this
with adelita
is it best for me to go in this
direction with this career or this
direction
and the the career path that gives you a
higher
level of consciousness and vibration
will test strong and something that
might
be not so favorable for your evolution
and self-development will test weak so
you can use muscle testing all over the
place so
back to john thief so i'm teaching touch
for health all over northeastern ohio
and and then on to other states in
florida
one year i find out at the annual
convention that i'm the person that's
taught
more people than anyone in the united
states
well they invited me to move from akron
to pasadena
and work as a a program director
for the touch for health foundation here
well
i ended up finding you know touch health
is fantastic and there's a lot of great
material there
but i'm teaching mainly health
professionals this and there's so much
material from good heart
as well as other doctors that i've
studied with like sheldon deal
who is on the he helped david hawkins
write the book power versus force by the
way yeah
so i'm like there's a lot of good
material that's beyond touch for health
that i think practitioners could really
benefit from
yes so then in 1992 i left the touch for
health foundation
and started my own kinesiology institute
where then i started certifying people
throughout the
well actually we have students now in 89
countries particularly online
wow that are that are using this all
over the world it's so exciting to hear
the results that they're having in in
their practice as well as their personal
lives
and that's a great thing about
everything you learn in this
you can and will demonstrate this today
you can use for yourself
yeah yeah so it's a it's a great way to
uh take you know the the the gems of and
it's a lot of
easy to use techniques and they're
non-invasive yes
and you know like you can get rid of
pain like in an instant
as well as an emotional pain and
suffering
yeah you know i've had times in my life
where i literally with some of the
challenges i went through
i would wake up in the morning saying i
just want to die
i don't want to be alive well
through using the techniques that are in
this work
i was able to totally shift that and
within a matter of
weeks i was like i'm back in my groove
i'm back
making a difference for other people and
living my mission and got out of my deep
suffering
it'll probably be helpful to unpack
some of the teachings of
touch for health good heart and then
touch for health
and then how you basically synthesized
that and kept adding your own
learnings into what you developed as
kinesiology institute yeah so let's kind
of
yeah let's walk and if we want to do
demos of
good heart and touch for health and yeah
yeah we can do those
right along the way so yeah walk us
through those and then how also like you
were describing how they're
tackling you know if there is that that
pain that's concentrated that's
physically
for some people or emotional you know
how are these
how do they help heal towards well-being
yeah
well start with a technique that we can
do right here and
people watching can do perfect when
i was invited to teach at the tony
robbins life mastery
university which i've been doing now for
27 years
since such a delight yes i asked john
thief well what should i show these
people he says
you ought to show them the ear unrolling
technique because it often gets
immediate results
and it's really easy and fantastic one
more time on the name of it
the ear unrolling technique ear
unrolling technique yeah okay and that's
what we're doing this is funny okay do
this
turn and everyone watching can do this
turn your head from right to left
and see if you have any stiffness or
tension in your neck from right to left
and then left to right doesn't matter
with the order okay just turn
one way and turn the other now i'm
noticing when i turn
to the right my neck's a little stiffer
okay so everyone do that as you're
watching now the technique's simple
what you're doing is you're taking the
rolled over part of your ear
and you're just unrolling it and pulling
it away from the opening and then
working down
towards the bottom of the ear and you
could do that about three or four times
so i'm just
and so i demonstrated this and i still
do every every
every presentation and i had one woman
in she was from london and she said she
had a car accident
earlier like a year earlier and she was
having all kinds of pain and stress in
her neck and
after doing this technique just taking
about 60 to 80 seconds
it totally relieved her neck tension
that's so cool yeah
so after doing that again you know four
or five times now
this is called like the dumbo technique
yeah it's like dumbo yeah you're making
your ears bigger
yeah yeah exactly yeah that's great and
so now
turn ahead again and see oh wow i'm
getting a lot better range of motion now
in that size me too yeah and so that's a
simple touch for health technique
yeah that is pretty that's really simple
and that was about a minute
of ear unrolling
yeah so it's kind of like an ear massage
really yeah it's like an unrolling and
pulling massage
technique that get and you do it all
across the ear
yeah and you do that so is there an
acupuncture
relationship there to yes to the neck
and is that it's called um
is that c1 is that what the top one is
called
well the top vertebrae in the neck is c1
i'll explain it yeah
okay the ears act as antennae for the
acupuncture meridian system
the acupuncture meridian system you can
think of it as is wireless
channels that are going along the
surface of the body
that have acupressure points or
acupuncture as you
you know if you've been to an
acupuncturist these points
along the the pathways of the meridian
are kind of like relay towers or
antennas that transmit these
this energy throughout the body and it
helps the body to function
and be at peace peak health so when our
bioelectrical energy also known as qi
is blocked or low
then we have basically health challenges
or at least low energy
you know or we're just not focused or
basically able to be at our best okay
so you want to have high levels of chi
and so
one way to boost your qi very simply is
doing this ear and rolling technique
while you're pulling on the ears and
unrolling it's sort of like telling the
the antenna to boost up and bring in
more chi bring in more energy
so not only is it good for stiff necks
it also helps to energize you energized
so now where on the acupuncture meridian
system
the ears are on that well
we'll keep unpack that more yeah where
are all the other ones yeah
well again it's it's more of a receptor
for all the chi
and there's there's other bodies
that this ocean is yeah so we're in the
ocean and there's a bioelectrical taurus
in a sense that is happening and the
more
constrained egoic levels have these
smaller
electromagnetic bioelectrical
fields and then the more you have a
state of unconditional love
and light and love energy uh the more
clear your chakras are
the more you resonate and the higher
frequency higher vibration
and so now within this acupuncture
meridian system the ears are
one of these kind of points that enable
a higher chi
and then there's other points that
enable these higher cheese
and so that's one of them are there
other ones that
you're like recommend that are simple
like where are these sure
yeah well let's go back to a little more
of the context
okay let's do it let's do it yes yeah so
we have many different energy
bodies and and flows within the body
like the chakras are one energy system
you know there's figure eight energy
flows and in my certification programs
we get and break these down
because everything affects everything
and that's one of the things
that um like you said your thought your
focus
your emotions they're affecting all this
you know what you eat
and your surroundings and the people
you're surrounded with
totally yeah everything affects
everything and so
one of the pathways that we work with a
lot within
applied kinesiology and touch for health
is the meridian system
so you can think of it as these highways
or pathways
and each meridian system governs
specific functions within the body as
well as organs that they're often
named after so we have a lung meridian
but it's also affecting every cell like
the the the flow of oxygen
within into the cell and carbon dioxide
out is
governed by the lung meridian okay and
then we have
a heart meridian which also
the function of blood getting in and out
of the cell so every cell
is like its own little body as well and
so
we have points a little like again
antennae along a meridian so let's just
take
um the lung meridian for instance
okay you can go from beginning to end by
just stroking
right along the surface of the body from
just
right up here inside the shoulder that's
lung one
and it goes down the palmar side
or the front of the forearm right along
to the thumbnail
right here so if you just stroke along
there
even just this yeah i do this
quite a bit is i just stroke my own body
yeah and just in general when we're
laying down
you know in our bed maybe in the morning
or at night or when we're just taking a
break to lay down
on the couch it's just so nice to just
undergo this it's a very self-love
process
yeah and you're whether you know it or
not
we're dealing with these acupuncture
meridians when we're doing these types
of
maneuvers it's so interesting yeah now
along the long meridian
there are certain points that are like
known as the tonification point
which is right at the radial artery
right here is the tonification
for lung which are people are you know
particularly with what's going on now
with covid you know and the lungs are
being affected this would be
a way to tonify what does that mean
tonify uh increased energy
increase energy flow okay okay thank you
for clarifying it sometimes when you get
in inside a system and you start using
jog and
jargon and people say what yeah okay so
it's a way to create
energy flow so you can just touch there
very lightly with i like to use the
thumb
or be the either the thumb or the index
and middle finger
and as you touch right there
that can help bring energy and flow into
it and then you can do the other side
yeah good d
always take a deep breath because that
also increases chi yes
breath in itself is life force it is
prana
it is yeah that's you know in that whole
pranayama
in yoga in fact i do alternate nostril
breathing before my meditation every day
and that brings the brain and the
neurotransmitters into balance so
yes so that's one point now conscious
breath can basically be
in many ways referred to as the nature
of reality
in many ways literally your breath is it
yeah yeah it's the simplest clearest way
to
bring yourself into balance and
consciousness
the tool that is always with us like
that
and then just that aw just the sheer awe
for the breath the off for the
consciousness
that in itself is so much of the nature
of reality yeah everyone take a deep
breath as you're watching
especially breathing in through the
belly and expanding the belly
and then relaxing it out okay so
let's do another acupressure point okay
this is a
when i teach in uh the tony robbins
program
if you're pregnant don't do this one by
the way this is
right on the back of the hand
between the first and second metacarpal
that's the hand bones
and you're pressing with your thumb
right here
and this can often can you bring that up
into your shot yeah let's have you bring
that up into your shot
there you go okay cool so that point
right there you've rubbed there that's
called large intestine
four whoa and this is often good for
headaches
can be good for tooth pain and it helps
to
bring energy a blocked energy out of the
head so especially given the technology
age and using
cell phones and keyboards this is one
that i do a lot
yeah yeah so that's another good point
and
you know so each point has its place and
function and that's where we
we also show in muscle testing how to
find
out where which points are blocked
and what it is and we'll show muscle
testing here in a little bit
is you can find out uh
when you have a strong muscle and then
that point is touched either by you
or the person testing you or you're
testing someone else and you're touching
their point or they are
and a strong muscle will then become
weakened
that is an indication that that point
needs stimulation
and that there's energy blocked there
interesting so
that's another one so when a strong
muscle weakens
that means there's energy blocked and it
needs stimulation if they're touching
the point yes
if they're touching the point okay yeah
because that was another main thing that
you said
in your first intro segment that i
wanted to make sure that we honed in on
which is the idea of these blockages
and in a sense when we had anthony
flores on the show he
talks about it like garden hoses knots
in the garden hose and then that's what
we're doing is we're doing the modality
of the assistance of unwinding that so
that the energy flows that she
is a lot more peak performance yeah yeah
yeah cool
yes and so we'll kind of unpack that as
well yeah fundamentally
any symptom you have is blocked energy
yeah you know and though the yeah the
roof
leaking and rather than cleaning up the
puddle that was a great analogy
yeah get up there yeah and so you you're
basically
finding where the energy's blocked but
also we use muscle testing to find out
what's blocking the energy
is it something in your physical realm
is it something in your nutritional
biochemical
body is it in your emotional and
your mental body you know can you tell
from an acupuncture meridian which one
of those three it is or from a muscle
test
it's a muscle it's a muscle so you'll be
able to determine
from the muscle test which of those
three also it is
or energetic you know like the
acupuncture meridians the chakras
uh again i'll give a demonstration okay
okay cool
so i can touch someone's back or they
can touch the back and
when you have a strong muscle and then
the point of the body where there's say
a symptom of stress whatever
is touched a strong muscle will test
weak
then we have ways of assessing
is that weakness have some structural
element
does it have a biochemical element does
it have
an emotional element and does it have an
electrical element
so i was working with this woman who was
a nurse practitioner
and she says yes i've had this back pain
for four years
so i say well let's test what's involved
in your back pain because
often we again if you have back pain
and you go to a therapist they'll do
massage or physical therapy or a doctor
might prescribe
you know a muscle relaxer or they'll do
whatever system
that they know everything if they're
if they have a hammer everything is a
nail or you know if they have a
screwdriver everything is a screw and
they just use their tool
hoping that'll fix it well when i
checked with her i said oh
it's actually emotional and energetic
and so she said well i'm not stressed
about anything and i said well how long
have you had this pain and she said four
years i said well was anything going on
in your life it was affecting you
emotionally four years ago and she said
oh yeah yeah well guess what
emotional stress gets locked in the body
and if you don't resolve it
it keeps holding on yeah and so
energetically
there was a blockage from that emotional
event four years ago
and then i also found there was an
energetic property
in the energetic field and this is a
brilliant quote by einstein he said
the energy field is the sole
governing agent of matter yeah
that our energy fields like the
acupuncture meridian system the auric
fields
um the chakras the the orc fields are
like layers of
energy surrounding the body and most
people don't see that with their eyes
but it's there and they have electrical
equipment there's a curling photography
that you can actually
observe that we just don't have the the
the sensitivity to pick up those
frequencies well in her case
i cleared her emotional stress from that
four years ago we have very simple
emotional stress release techniques to
show
and then she ended up through that and
working on the org field
so god the back pain is totally gone and
i talked to her later and it hadn't come
back
yeah so that's where again you're
looking at
what aspect and it's often a combination
of them
totally another guy had knee pain and
his he had
knee surgery but it didn't fix it so
they said well
we're gonna have to do a knee
replacement
well he's a dance instructor and he said
i can't afford to be
off work that much i'll lose all my
students and my my business will go
down the drain so he comes to me in fact
i met him at a tony robbins program when
i was presenting there
and he said well can you see what's
going on and again instead of me
throwing my toolbox at him
i said let's assess through muscle
testing what
is your individual situation
came up was primarily nutritional and
some structural
and i found out there were certain foods
he was eating particularly wheat that he
would eat every meal
that was creating an inflammatory
condition
and that then was causing his knee pain
well he got weed out of his diet and we
did some structural balancing
and i followed him for 16 years he never
needed the knee surgery and he was able
to continue doing his
his dance in instruction and
was fine wow no no more pain because he
knew
oh and that's often the case see we
don't realize the food we're eating
exactly is often creating our physical
and emotional problems that's right we
have people that clean up their diet and
their depression and anxiety goes away
that's right
so there's that's where again the
holistic nature of the system
and the beauty of muscle testing is you
can assess
what it is for this person because some
pers people will have
emotional low back other will have
structural factors we need to clear
uh others will have like the energetic
factors
i had one woman who had a chronic
hip pain and doctors couldn't
every doctor she'd been to nothing would
help yeah
and so i'm testing it comes up its inner
auric field
so i'm working with her in a crystal and
clearing the energy field
around her hip never even touching her
hip and she says oh my god it feels like
you just took a vacuum
cleaner and pulled the pain out of my
body i mean it sometimes
amazes me it's like wow how that could
be so
phenomenally effective yeah you know and
and there's times where people need a
hip replacement you know there's
sometimes and i i want people to be
aware of
i'm not saying don't do conventional
medical tests and i always say rule
things out
you know and yet when they're not
helping and they can't find anything
there's something in the vibrational
field that doesn't show up in lab
reports
you know like the we call it subclinical
a lot of people have like subclinical
thyroid
you know well they had the tests and
everything looks good or
the adrenal glands there's another one
that are often you know
we call it low adrenal hypoadrenia from
all the stress people are going through
and so many factors that
if you just look at the energetic
and vibrational frequencies of the body
and assess the entire body
then you're able to see well what we
have a way of
establishing the priorities often the
chakras show up as priorities
and when you clear people's chakras
often their lives
totally transform yes just you know
which is a lot what happened with me
when i'm going
to from beer and pizza totally
yeah to the the buddha and pranayama i
changed my bees in peace
and i started balancing my chakras and
uh
you know my whole life changed i'm so
fascinated by
seeing and learning which
tests in the muscle testing
what the exact nuanced strategies
are on your end to determine whether
it's physical
or biochemical or emotional and mental
i'm really interested in sure yeah so
should we should we do
some of that you know uh perhaps i can
show how to do self-testing perfect
that'd be good okay
is that the there's a new one yeah we
can do it yeah okay great um
probably good time to zoom zoom out then
and i'll get behind that center cam
sure so i'm going to man some of the
middle camera for
um some of this content and then we'll
also be standing up for some of it so
we'll be adjusting that center shot for
you guys
yeah so one of the ways i self-test
is i bring my knee up
and the foot out a little bit in front
and then you can do this along with me
i put my palm on the end of my thigh
just right above the knee
and i meet my pressure kind of like i'm
pushing i'm holding the knee up
and then i push down towards the floor
and i'm meeting my pressure so i'm i'm
pushing with
first like the weight of my hand a
little harder a little harder a little
harder about eight pounds of pressure
okay now i then ask my body
to give me a no response
meaning i want to see what the body does
when
it is basically showing me energy
blockage or stress you can think of it
that way
so you can even do this as i say body
give me a no and i think of a stressor
and then when i push i just give way so
i might think of a frustrating thought
okay now rather than be in your head
you want to be in your gut and allowing
your body
being open to the result and giving say
body give me accurate information that's
the
intention i'm having an intention
of getting accurate information from my
in innate intelligence yes getting your
head out of it and say
intelligence give me a response yes now
i say body give me a yes
and i think of a happy thought so
everyone can try that
again if you have the foot a little
further in front it engages this muscle
here called the quadriceps so body give
me a no
body give me a yes okay now
okay so so again the recap is that
um we're gonna be in our body we're
gonna land in our energetic
body away from the head and so we're
here and we're lifting up the leg
and we're saying you know we're thinking
something around
a happy positive thought we're getting a
body give me a body give me a yes and
we're really in
and we have that engagement of the quad
and then if it's you know something
around anger or misery or suffering
you know body give me a no so easy body
give me a no
give me a yes yeah okay all right all
right
okay so now we have that and so it's
almost the
completely we're we're not even using
in a sense even our conscious perception
around this it's just
more a relaxed state it's a very
relaxed innate intelligence state
okay and the more you do it the better
you get at it
yes exactly so that's that's the leg
test
there was there was one that i was doing
i was watching john's videos
and i was doing one which we'll probably
demo when we're standing
up and i'm looking forward to that one
as well because that one has a lot to do
with
sort of the more that you do these the
more that you get into especially
like should i have you know two ounces
four ounces six ounces of this thing and
you can literally can
you can tell which way you're swinging
yeah and we'll do some of that okay yeah
cool cool
yeah so i i'll show one little thing
to show an emotional if emotional
clearing would help
yeah okay okay cool so i'm gonna go
again with the the foot test here and
i'm gonna think of a stressor
okay so i'll think of a stressor
right now i've got oh i got to get my
taxes ready okay so i think about
getting my taxes ready and when i think
about that and push on my leg i totally
go weak
okay yeah now there are stress release
points on the forehead
they're called the frontal eminences
they're like right here where the
the forehead kind of has a little bump
or ridge those eminences that's what a
kind of a protrusion on the forehead and
we often touch them
when we're under stress instinctively
like we go oh my gosh that's right
ah now physiologically what this does is
it gets more blood flow
and oxygen into particularly the
emotional centers of your brain
to help clear the stress yeah so what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to touch here again and
think about my taxes
doing my taxes oh and now it's strong
see so without that thinking the taxes i
go weak
and i think about doing my taxes and i'm
strong so that's just an example i mean
anything you're stressed about
if you touch here and you think about it
it clears it energetically to help you
not be so stressed about it yeah and and
again
it unblocks energy it gets energy
flowing from
the back of your brain where our old
association area is
to the front of your brain which is
called the new association area
which we'll talk about more later but
it's just a very simple technique
and you don't rub you just touch lightly
right like this just touch and hold now
what i'll often do
is before i go to sleep i'll
in fact i'll even go to sleep with my
hands here i'll be lying
you know say on my side and i'll just
put my hands here
and i'll go off to sleep or like this
and that
is able to clear a lot of the stress of
the day
and help you fall asleep better so
anytime you're having insomnia
do some slow deep breathing touch here
and then just let your body unwow
yeah so that's that's a great technique
tony actually shows that
in the life mastery program that i teach
at beautiful
and um and it's just profound you can do
that with other people
you know like if you for mothers or
fathers if your kids stressed
uh or anybody here you know i do this
with my uh
my clients in in sessions where they're
you know stressed about something i'll
hold these points and then have
just doing slow deep breathing it's
really one of the easiest
techniques in touch for health and
applied kinesiology
yeah so that's a a simple one but i'm
showing how
when you we talked about this earlier
when something
is like testing weak like taxes yeah
taxes
you will do it yeah yeah it's a taxing
situation
okay so when you have energy blockage
that was a thought or emotional
blockage and you touch a point that will
help to correct that
it goes from weak to strong okay i want
to also
get in this and and give it a go
interesting so yeah
all right so yeah taxes are definitely
not a favorite of mine either so
all right so taxes okay that's what's
this
how about smoothie yeah that's holding
okay taxes okay
so now taxes
do you notice how it strengthens when
you yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so you know and you don't have to
muscle test
to do this technique i mean you know i i
just do it whenever i'm stressed about
anything
uh and it helps to clear it totally
really quickly and again it's just that
the even just that
touch component itself especially like
you say
you know the prefrontal cortex or you
said the mental eminence is what you
were frontal
frontal eminence that means the frontal
bone this is the frontal bone exactly
and it's the eminence or bump on the
frontal bone yeah
so that's what you're touching on both
sides just about
three fingers width above the eyebrows
and you're just touching it with the
pads of the fingers
very lightly you're not rubbing you're
just touching and holding
and another little tip is you can
slightly tug up on the skin
towards the hairline and just touch and
hold oh that's nice too
that's so nice yeah and again tony
robbins is
is showing this now i originally
presented that
back in the uh you know in the early
days and now he's even
incorporating this in this program
because it's so simple
and yet so profound i've had people with
major stressors
that doing this help to clear it now
even when you're touching here you can
focus on the stressor
and whatever happened in the past that
you're stressed about
but what you're doing is you're changing
the neural association
where instead of when you think of it
energy blockage stress going into fight
or flight
you know your body is in a lower state
of consciousness turning the tax into
something that's a little more relaxing
it's got energy flow on it and then you
actually
start thinking of new ways it's like oh
i just thought my new assistant
i'm going to turn that uh uh that job
over to her
so i'm going to have her working my
quickbooks up and then i'm going to get
that to my accountant and
and i see it now all being complete
you know rather than oh god we go into
these catastrophic expectations i don't
want to do this and i don't
resistance basically the pragmatic
benefits
of this are are re-baselining
ourselves to a state of peace and bliss
on that 24 7 basis which is what the
spiritual
perennial wisdoms are which is when you
go inward and
recognize that consciousness is it that
you recognize more and more that
i feel that well of bliss
and peace on a moments moment basis even
though there's taxes
even though there's these things that
quote
appear for some people to be like
suffering
we still jedi
and ninja our way through it peacefully
and blissfully harmonically
and so it so this is one this is one of
many
of the muscle tests now we have we have
other ones we have
tests so we should stand now yeah okay
and i just want to cap on what you said
yes
is it's when we resist our experience
i know this is so key and what you were
just talking about
is it's about flow it's about flow don't
resist flow even if you're
you're finding yourself upset or angry
or
you know feeling any let's say lower
vibrational frequency emotion
accept it and flow with it and just be
with it
see they we have a saying whatever you
can
feel and express you can heal
that's it but if you resist it's not
life that
brings us down and kills us it's
resisting life
in our experience so just flow with your
experience
and then when you're in a state of flow
you've got energy flow you've got then
completion things you know magically
even you meet the right person you know
that it all comes together like we met
you know it's like
when you're in the flow your life is
like your dharma just
unfolds you don't have to you don't have
to force it there's
no force yeah and the the analogy of the
perennial wisdoms across
mystic traditions is the oceanic-ness
it's that the more that we recognize
that
consciousness is that pure bear
awareness of the oceanic
infinitude that is eternal and then it's
always being
colored by the waves the waves are the
experiences the thoughts emotions
feelings beliefs
objects sensations perceptions
taste smell touch all those things
that then what happens is we learn how
to ride the crest
yeah of the wave do we surf that crest
david hawkins and all of these other
surf on the crest and versus when we
swim
against the currents and that we're
resisting
and so these strategies they help in the
process of
relaxing into the wave into the
experience yeah yeah so yeah let's show
the sway test this one i use
more than anything yeah
okay so we get out of the microphone
here
so when you're doing the standing test
the sway test am i a good angle for you
yeah you should see it right yeah you
got it
okay yeah so what i do is i have my feet
about shoulder width apart
and then i focus again on my gut
and i'll think a happy feeling and
thinking the word yes
yes yes yes and i notice i sway forward
most people do
now i'm going to think a frustrating
thought
i can't think of the taxes anymore
because it doesn't trust me
okay uh let's see um
oh boy um okay well just the amount of
work i need to
get accomplished this week okay and i
think of that no
no and then i think the word no no no so
everyone you can just
stand and do this as you're watching so
think of a happy thought
and see if you go forward or back and
just again tune into your gut they call
it the
don tien down here below your navel and
that's your body's center intelligence
and see
a yes goes forward for me and then i
think a no
and then upsetting thought and i go back
okay
now how i can then use that is i can
take
um say again a
thought or maybe a decision i'm wanting
to do so i'm thinking about okay
is it good for me to work on this
project
tomorrow is in my highest benefit to
work on this project tomorrow so i'm
thinking of a project
oh and i'm getting a no so i'm going to
think of another project that i'm
looking to take on and that one's saying
a yes
see so a lot of times they won't know
what i do today you know what's my
highest
uh best intention for the day yes and i
got three or four different ones that i
can choose from
okay now you can also think of a food
so i'm gonna think of a food okay i've
got one in mind
oh and i'm going back okay it's
interesting because it's one of the
things we're going to actually
eat should we bring it out absolutely
okay great
this one okay well let's do this one
yeah okay so now i've got sugar here
okay so i'm going to hold the sugar if
you have the food you can hold it
especially against your midline and
when i hold it i sway back okay
so you want to just should i bring the
plate up and we can
take one food at a time so we have a
we have a plate of uh
blueberries carrots
grapes strawberries all right so which
one shall we
well let me let me grab oh these
strawberries look great okay
now if you can smell the food that's
going
into your olfactory nerve even better
so i'm going to smell the strawberry and
see what i get
okay and it's leaning forward okay so
now let me grab the grape
okay
i can even taste a little bit
okay got the taste oh
i'm going back home and that's actually
what i thought about earlier is sticky
in the grape
oh yeah but so for me the grape isn't
doing it
okay okay let me grab a blueberry see
how i do on the blueberries today
i'm not getting a strong yes or strong
note it's interesting i did already have
blueberries earlier
wild organic blueberries yeah and my
body is saying
yeah but it's not like saying oh that
would really be
yeah yeah ideal for me now i do this
with smoothies
in the morning where i'll i open the bag
of the
you know frozen yeah yes like
blueberries and
strawberries and i have acai you know
i'll smell it and if i
go forward that's what i put in my
smoothie that day yeah and i'll show it
on tea as well okay so here's a carrot
yeah okay oh
how about that so for me the carrot
isn't the thing to do
now also we have good seeds yeah the
teas
now just to note sometimes if you have a
commercial groud carrot
and an organic carrot you might get a
different response yeah
and it's not to say oh carrots are never
good for me
but it's something that right now
my body is not wanting that see we have
bio-individuality and what's good for
you
might be not good for me or what's good
for me one day is not good enough
so let's just take a t here so we got
lipton tea
so i smell that and i get a sway back
so not so good now let's get another tea
here
okay so this is an herbal tea i can
smell it and
oh i go really forward so those are
are ways i use every day to see
you know what is my best energy
at that moment so um and i'll go to the
market
and i'll hold like i was at trader joe's
last night and i was holding
certain food and uh if
like i can't remember if it was
i think it was eggs well should we give
back some money
okay yeah let's get back to your next
cool yep we can talk now
this is interesting just to even like to
think about
okay so that's strawberry yeah you get a
good hit on the strawberry
i am okay all right carrot
oh a little bit more back a little bit
more back now
is that and it's not it's that specific
carrot is that a commercial grown or is
it
organic do you know i'm not sure
yes and you're good on the blue yeah
i'm on the strawberry blueberries right
now yeah that's what it
and the teas
i mean i'll probably even do that lift
and it's like this one's
faster for you yeah but you were okay on
the lipton now
it's almost it's very i just want to say
this it's very
very let's see how this angle it's okay
for now i'll go and
i'll angle it down quick but i know this
one's gonna i i already have a
this one's yeah i see uh sugar fine
sugar is not
the not the thing that it's on yeah okay
let's bring this in for now if we want
to stand back up we will
um we're probably done with the standing
for now i think
yeah we've demonstrated that enough i
think so i'm going to just mention about
coffee
i know yeah you had the story and i know
you're going to mention coffee i just
want to say this so bad
this is so interesting because what you
said
what you said a moment ago is so
accurate
with this um with foods is that
basically the more that you do this
the more it becomes you unleash the
innate intelligence
yeah of the muscle testing the
connection we're talking about you
connect with it
it's extremely intuitive
it's extremely sensitive to the body's
intelligence
and you just it becomes more and more
of that subtlety over time and and you
can almost kind of ride with the flow of
that oceanic waveness
a little bit more like whoa you can hear
its voice
yeah you can hear its voice yeah pull up
a little bit more in the chair again
okay
a little bit more pull up a little bit
more okay
is this good perfect that's good
beautiful
okay so yeah so we're on coffee now was
that where you were yeah like
i have this really healthy organic
coffee it's got some
um like mushroom that's blended with it
and it's like a great antioxidant coffee
and i find that some days i'll open the
bag and smell the coffee
and it always smells great but some days
when i smell it i go
forward and then i'll take it and then
the next day maybe forward and then
maybe a third day
i go back that's right see so our body
likes variety and if you keep doing
something every day like a lot of people
they just eat the same thing the same
thing
they drink the same beverage every
morning every morning every morning
and what i was finding is when i would
would if i didn't listen to my body and
i would keep drinking that coffee my
adrenals were getting very depleted
that's right
so i i'd say oh the next day i'm maybe
slippery elm
is the tea i go forward on and then
sometimes i'm good on earl grey i got an
organic earl grey and i do well in that
but my body likes variety so therefore
even though it's a healthy coffee
and i love it my body says i need a
break
and if i'm asking every day i know
whether
oh that morning if i go back and skip it
today
that's right and you know tomorrow maybe
i'll be
good on it but that's i just like to
have
the best energy i can throughout the
entire day
and this way you can tap into your
innate intelligence and say
body what's going to give me the highest
energy today yep
rather than oh i'm going through these
dips and i'm back up and then especially
with
with coffee and stimulates we think oh
if
our energy's low then i need to get a
five hour energy or a monster drink well
that actually
it i every time i test on five hour
energy
i never drink it but i have one at home
just for testing purposes
and you know it just it's you don't you
don't get back
a yes on five hours i have not no yeah
exactly
or red bulls or monsters oh absolutely
not yeah even in the morning like you're
describing with getting into the ritual
or the routine of even a healthy coffee
is that to be able to use the innate
intelligence and see
are you potentially getting the answer
to go with an herbal tea
and sometimes it's literally i feel like
we are just
children that need a pacifier in the
morning of something hot
and so if you try the hot tea
like an herbal one and just see how that
interplays with you
and maybe instead of going really hard
like
caffeinated maybe you kind of relax back
with like
a book for like the first hour or two of
the day and kind of like
let your blood pressure just naturally
rise
yeah like in the day rather than just
going hard in the morning yeah stuff
like that let me give you another energy
tip
yeah okay there's a the thymus gland
it's a john diamond dr john diamond
writes in his book life energy how this
helps to regulate our life force and if
you just thump on it
it's right around where your second
button is here interesting
and we even for you that remember tarzan
movies
yeah he would beat right there and i
don't know if they knew
it was actually a physiological switch
it is yeah
so i'll do that in the morning in fact
every morning cool
but right before my meditations i'll
just thump right on this
now there's another acupressure point
right here
called conception vessel 24. it's a
meridian that runs right up the
front this midline of the body it ends
right here under
the lower lip and that dip in the chin
and if you tap there
it actually helps to stimulate dopamine
so that's another
energizer wow um while we're on the
energy thing we already talked about the
urine rolling technique so in other
words instead of just going for that
morning cup
do some deep breathing often ride my
bike in the morning
exactly go out in the sun run around
yeah also get on the earth
get your feet barefoot on the earth it's
called grounding
like i live right at the beach i'll go
out in the sand with my bare feet
or if you're on grass if you can um
i know in some climates it's it's called
winter weather right now but if you can
get on natural connected with the earth
yes and that's an energizer uh the urine
rolling technique here's another one
pull apart on this it's called the
sagittal suture between the two bones
here called the parietal bone
breathe in and pull apart like you're
trying to open up
um the skull and breathe in
pull apart and then exhale relax and
then
pull apart as you breathe in exhale
relax
deep breath in exhale relax
in doing that that's another energizer
on a biochemical or supplement
uh the amino acid tyrosine it's called
l-tyrosine a 500 milligram
capsule i take one first thing in the
morning that also stimulates your
dopamine which is what
coffee and stimulants do and so we're
always trying to
let's say self-medicate to get us to be
to feel good
you know and so in the the case of
coffee oh we're raising our dopamine
the problem with again it's it's there's
good quality coffees and there's ones
that are not so good but an organic
coffee
and how much your body wants which you
also mentioned about the ounces
see i can muscle test and i'll do it
with my
my my knee up here and i'll say okay
more than four ounces
more than six ounces okay six ounces
seven ounces six so i can actually see
how much of the coffee
you know so so i find if i have
like say in my body's case six ounces i
feel great but if i say oh let me have
some more let me have some more then i
go over the top
and that's very similar the exercises
that
you had me do thanks to your content
that's also available online where you
walk us through
these like multi-hour long sessions
across
muscle testing and other aspects of
kinesiology where you can do this
process where you go okay
tonight you know two ounces of wine
three ounces of wine four ounces of wine
and you're
already starting to go backward when
you're getting into the higher ounces
and then
similarly maybe with the another one
that i played with was the
milligrams of of cannabis is another one
like five milligrams 10 milligrams 20
you know you i i started going back like
right after 20 or right after maybe four
six ounces of wine as well
like you really kind of want to you want
to muscle test those
numbers as well and then stick to that
like two glasses or whatever
you test it in at yeah yeah and so yeah
and in
our kinesiology institute.com we have
a way people get free a free three-day
course
that shows a lot more of these
techniques they'll go way beyond and
like specific acupressure points like
for headaches and
and a lot of the ways you're using this
to again have better health better
energy
and and a longer life exactly my
my goal is to be teaching this uh
at least to 100 years old in fact my
oldest student she started she came to
my class when she was 95.
her name was irene harrison wow and i
asked her irene
uh what are you here for and she says
well i don't care if i live to be 105
i'm gonna keep on learning i love that
in fact she was not only
in my kinesiology classes she's also a
yoga student of mine and she come to
yoga class
95 98 years old and she actually made it
to 108 years old
wow and uh she
she was amazing she was a friend
of thomas edison's wow
see thomas edison's wife uh was from
akron
wow well irene's father started goodyear
tire and rubber company
wow so they were like they were like you
know
drinking buddies and so she would go
over to thomas edison's house
and after a session that i was working
with her one day
she sat up and she said you know you're
doing what my old friend
thomas edison said the doctor of the
future will do
beautiful the doctor the future will
give no drugs or medicine
but he will educate his patient
in the care of the human frame in
diet and in the cause and prevention
of disease exactly so that's what we're
doing you know it's it's it's in your
body
will educate you that's your innate
intelligence isn't stupid
it knows what you should eat and that's
why for me testing
you know i don't test everything i'm
like i
kind of lo i know in in even
without muscle testing if you you really
get tuned into your innate intelligence
it tells you it's your you know your
intuitive like your gut
feeling your intuition knows what's good
and what's not
and even dr thief the one who created
touch ralph told me says you know
eventually we'll be so in tune we won't
need the muscle test
that's what i was also wanting to chat
about which is probably
it's probably a good segue into that
yeah
is this sort of
riding on the crest of each wave when we
get
so intuitively good at it we end up
not needing the muscles the muscle test
in a sense is
training wheels for the highest level of
intuitive flow
yeah yeah i see so i don't want people
think oh god now i got a muscle test
every move i make you know and
everything i'm putting in my body in
that it's
it's in basically it boils down to
is this food rich in life force
yes yes and it's basically your organic
produce plant-based organic produce and
for those that are
you know uh wanting like free-range
organic like meats and that
you know for those that find that's okay
and it's again it's a bio-individual
thing
it is like some people i was a
vegetarian strict vegetarian for eight
years
and i found my energy was just
really getting low and so i ended up
having a steak one day
for like first time at in eight years
like wow do i
feel great great yeah it's so
interesting and
and yet i have like sheldon deal he's
been
he's been a vegetarian for i think at
least let's see
60 i guess 60 years
he's been a vegetarian yeah and for him
that works fine
yeah you know so it's not one size fits
all
exactly it's super bio-individual and
it's there's so much complexity in the
gut microbiome
as well for each person yeah i wonder
we should probably chat about this a bit
because it's so
obviously critical for um
the future of of
humanity which is that
we have a we'll bring up multiple of
these as we talk
so oh yes yeah we have david hawkins
levels of consciousness and specifically
the reason why i want to even bring this
up is its relationship to
the ego
and force which is down there in the
zero to 200 range
and then the enlightenment
and power upwards which is in that
closer to 1 000
range and the people in the positions of
power
around the planet fortune 500 ceos
the un general assembly the 2 200
billionaires on the planet 225 000 ultra
high net worth around the planet the
usa congress you know all these
different
people in positions of power and being
able to
map their levels of egoic
separation and find those garden
hose knots and then be able to help
catalyze a process of creating
the energy flows that enable
the piercing the veil towards that
self-realization
and towards that more harmonic
and abundant and prosperous architecting
of the future
fabric that we are
so excited to enable
the future of maximizing human potential
and so
this is sort of where i want to see a
conversation with you at a pragmatic
level
around especially the people in the
greatest amounts of power
and just you know we have this other one
that
that you brought with today
which is the you know it comes it comes
along
with some of the further
you know that's the same graphic and it
was brought with
john today so walk us through sort of
the these different levels on the
hawkins levels of consciousness and
also how the influence that
we can catalyze not only for ourselves
but for the positions
for the people in the positions of
greatest power and just
unraveling those garden hose knots
well it starts with looking at our own
consciousness
and where we're at and the name of the
game is
to elevate your consciousness yeah in in
all your thoughts
in in deeds in your life
purpose and mission and
and there's times where you because of
life
and things that happened to you that you
are in a deep state of let's say grief
or anger or maybe guilt
and the first step is just to
acknowledge that's where you're at
it's except in fact acceptance is a
higher level above 200
just to give you a background hawkins
would um he would muscle test
and he gives a an arbitrary thousand
you know thousand points on the scale in
this logarithmic
so um when you have a frequency
which he goes 200 or lower
that's something that would actually
muscle test weak yeah
and be a stressor for you and again it's
from an ego
i'm separate from others and so
when you feel like you're separate from
others and they're not meeting your
expectations you can get angry
or you can get sad or
you know a state of shame is the lowest
on the the scale
so first aware oh i'm in this state i'm
in a reactive mind a reactive mode
and so by going to love and acceptance
we actually have a technique for this
is there's a point and they talk about
this in emotional freedom technique
it's it's called stomach or no it's
actually small intestine three it's an
acupressure point
they call it the karate chop point so
i would say even though i'm feeling
very angry about this situation going on
in my life and you can
everyone can do this if they have an
anger or it could be a sadness or
whatever their upset is around
i totally again we'll start from the
beginning so even though i have this
situation in my life
that i feel very upset with i totally
and completely
love and accept myself it can be about
yourself say even though i feel
shame around this thing or even though i
feel guilty about this
situation in my life i totally and
completely
love and accept myself that's right and
then you can do both of them together
even though i have this situation that
i'm feeling
upset about i totally truly and
completely love and accept myself
and what that does alone is it brings
you up
into that higher plane of consciousness
it does yeah so
love and acceptance loving yourself is
the greatest love of all i think there
is a song about that right
learning to love yourself is the
greatest love
it's whitney houston but i think george
benson was the first one that did that
and so that's where whatever's going on
in your lower fields of consciousness
love and accept it don't resist it
the more you say i hate that about
myself
locks you in because what you resist
persists
but when you love and accept that part
of yourself
and just allow it to be it's like
the caterpillar that's going in
the cocoon and then coming out the
butterfly that's right
so transformation is a process of
letting go
in fact those are three key words in
life whatever you're holding on to
let it go and that's where this you know
let it go yeah let it go so good yeah
and so when you're
surrender yeah yeah and so
yeah so the lower states are like shame
guilt
uh grief um there's
uh when you move into anger you're
actually moving
up the scale so sometimes like when i
was in deep states of sadness
i actually became very angry
and knowing that when you
can feel something and express it you
can heal it
so the worst thing is to just bottle it
up and say well
i don't want to feel it or take a drug
so i deaden my
nervous system my consciousness so i
just allow myself to be with it
now the key is you don't want to act out
that anger
because i mean towards another person
because then that
when people are in fact if you yell at
someone
that makes them yell back and angry back
so what i first do is i'll say okay on
my own even though i'm
really angry right now give another tip
there's a point stomach one
where we tap when you have an emotional
upset
right under the eyes at the top of the
cheekbone and i use two fingers the
thumb
i mean the thing the index and the
middle finger together
breathing deep and i'll focus on
whatever it could be anger it could be
fear
could be anxiety it could be grief just
focusing on that while you tap
helps to balance the energy and remove
the blockage i had one time where i was
approaching someone i say oh my god i
i feel so angry at this person what i'm
about to do could end up putting me in
prison
so i'm breathing and tapping here
as i'm walking towards that person and
the anger just
melted and within 30 seconds i was able
to express myself to that person
and be able to say hey there's a
situation
that i'm finding you know gets me a lot
i'm getting very upset about
and i i have a request would you be
willing to do this
and by making the request and if they
said
in this case yes i can do that then i
just let it go
because you're looking for what's rather
than focusing on the problem what's the
solution and
and how can i come from a state of
consciousness where we are one
you know being like we're connected on a
higher plane because ultimately that's
what happens when you move above 200
you're in a state of consciousness where
we're all one
yeah ramdas used to say when
you know your true self and i know my
true self there's only one of us
exactly so that's getting to that state
and so
i just can't it's hardly ever do i get
upset with anyone
because really the source of upset is
uh unfulfilled expectation a thwarted
intention which is where i'm wanting
something to happen it doesn't happen
uh and a broken rule where i
say this person should be this way in
that way and they shouldn't do this or
that
like well the good news the the news is
other people are not in this world to
live up to your expectations
and you're not in this world to live up
to theirs
so if we can see what is it we want to
accomplish together
and what is the the world we want to
create together
that's where the beauty is that's where
we get
a world that works for everyone so
when you're using this whole map of
consciousness
what i i ultimately say is
how can i create peace the highest level
right under enlightenment how can i
create peace
with myself with everyone in my life
and what with whatever has happened in
my life
to be at peace with it in that way
i can then come to the highest level of
consciousness
to evolve yes yes that's basically
yeah to be at a state of peace with
everyone and everything
yeah the even just the
loving yourself and accepting yourself
and moving beyond the zero to 200 range
towards an acceptance is just such a
massive step
that is by far the first most important
step
and then beyond acceptance is just
the further kind of self-realization
process piercing the veil recognizing
that when you're your true self i'm your
true self we're only one being
and that that is what the well of honey
is
it is that peace and bliss it is that
natural state of pure consciousness that
is eternally being colored
by experience and that is what this is
that is what we've been
doing that is what will continue
happening and so this is the most
important thing for not only people to
get at an individual level but for the
businesses that affect our world and for
all of the
people in the largest positions of power
that affect our world for
us to baseline people away from sort of
pride and desire and especially the
self-dealing intentions of the ego
greed conspicuous consumption and
towards intentions that are of joy peace
and bliss
and enlightenment and recognizing that
there is no other
but that it's just a unique expression
of that one god
source infinitude that's occurring and
so
once we get people in positions of power
into states
of consciousness that are elevated like
that
that's when we can really have the
enlightened civilization that
is maximizing human potential i know
dennis kucinich who's from cleveland
ohio said why don't we create a cabinet
of peace
you know a department of peace rather
than a war department you know
and uh and exactly the more we you know
it all comes down to voting
and and and just the other thing is we
we have this
we're right and they're wrong and that's
the unfortunate polarity we
we see a lot in our world today is how
we can come with what is it we want to
all create and we all want
to have a a a safer
loving world for our children to grow up
into
you know and how in really raising
consciousness is the ultimate
solution to all problems 100 yeah and so
rather than being in this
anger it's saying okay let's see how we
can come to common ground
and that we have shared values
that we have to make the world a better
place to have a better place for our
children to grow up into
to have uh love in our hearts and so
even
and ramdas talked about this how he had
a picture of
some political person that he despised
on his altar
and he would have you know his guru and
jesus and all this
and then and he would he would actually
love his innocence enemy to say i need
to
let go of hate towards people that's
right
and just loving people and that's where
you know when when the cold war really
ended
tony robbins talks about this because he
asked gorbachev
and he said when the cold war out well
he said they were they were arguing him
and reagan were arguing in this talk
and so ronald reagan said hey let's go
out for a walk
and then they went out for a walk and he
said let's start fresh and he says hi
my name's ron and he said
that they um they dropped
the image of each being the evil empire
we're gonna see hey let's be as brothers
let's connect at a at a higher level
exactly
and you know okay we don't need all
these nuclear warheads pointing at each
other
which unfortunately there's still a lot
of that going on
but but it comes from your own your own
raise your own consciousness because
that's the one
the one person you can work on raising
your consciousness
and hawkins talks about this in the book
that people that are
that are high levels of consciousness
like say gandhi for instance
had such a profound power
that's where he calls the power versus
the force that was a stronger power
than the entire say
british army and military yeah
that that vibration influenced millions
of people
and so when you raise your consciousness
you have a stronger
more powerful effect totally over a
a much uh much greater
power yeah i love the geopolitical
example that you gave when you do
relax back into the oneness when you
relax back
into what we're going to talk about here
in a moment the non-duality
the more that we recognize the infinite
perfection that this
is now and we bring other people into
that to inch
to butterfly effect out even more
harmonic
peace bliss love compassion
understanding flourishing
rather than the egoic separate entity
which is more and more beginning to
dissolve
into the hot tea of the infinite and so
that's one of my yeah favorite analogies
thanks to rupert spire most recently
that i've been
talking about quite a bit so this would
probably be the good time to transition
into that which would be something like
would it be
i'm curious how you
see this multi-layered approach so at
the very
height of the non-duality
of the perennial wisdom
on a planetary level is that
everything is absolutely indescribably
perfect just
simply this
and there's another layer which is where
you can enter into the
duality which is where you say things
like
okay well they're suffering and there's
well-being and we're trying to eradicate
suffering and we're trying to maximize
well-being on a planetary level
is this how how do your frameworks align
with something
like that well each day
it's like living into the question
where am i going to find joy today where
am i going to create
peace where am i going to create love
and compassion
and so you become like a beam
of bringing and spreading that
so for me each interaction that i have
with someone like
for instance when i was checking out
at a store last night my favorite one
was i was at the dmv in hawaii
and i was getting my uh i used to live
in hawaii and it's in waimea hawaii and
i go to the dmv and you know we're in
this long line and
and so i get to the the woman at the
thing and she's helping me out and i
said i just wanted
i just want to let you know how much i
appreciate how great you are
exactly and how how it's it's actually a
pleasure to be here
exactly and she almost fell over it's
like no one's ever said that
it's like everyone's complaining and so
and then you have the smoothest
easiest most frictionless experience
possible yeah rather than god have been
in this line for 30 minutes and when can
you
this is so frustrating yeah it's just to
appreciate people
exactly uh i once interviewed you know
who uh wally famous wally amos
you know famous amos and i interviewed
him once
and he he goes and does these incredible
uh keynote speeches and i said do you
have like an
outline you use when you're doing these
and you got your stories all lined up he
says no he says
i only go in there with one commitment
and that commitment
is to have those people feel better
about themselves
than when they came in so
in every interaction i just feel like
how can i make this person feel better
about themselves
you know maybe another way to say that
would be
have you gotten to a point where it's
just a deep
surrender to the absolute flow of
this because there's when you say
that how can i right how can
i maximize the potential of the scenario
right there's sort of that that in a
sense is
what i've understood to be more of the
adding in that more
free will style aspect to it
whereas what i've recognized more and
more to be the absolute indescribable
surrender to just the unfolding
yeah of this do you
how does that resonate well that is
in michael beckwith talks about that you
know there's
the lowest level of consciousness is
victim they're doing it to me you know
oh this is that and the government's
doing this and isn't that
and then you get to the next level of
consciousness where you become proactive
and say oh
i'm going to create my own reality and
that
i can make you know and that's important
states you get to where hey i could be
proactive and i can create this
you know wonderful life but then when
you go beyond that
you go i just in a state of surrender
and
let the spirit run my life is the song
they actually have
yeah and i just surrender into the day
yeah and and that's where i'm not even
i'm not like intentionally
thinking oh i got to make this person
feel better about themselves it's just a
natural flow
exactly where it's effortless exactly
it's just that's what
it's a way of being that's what lauzon
meant by wu wei
effortless action yeah once you pierce
the veil and self-realize
yourself and everybody else as
the one infinite creator or god or
source or non-duality
whatever you want to say about it the
universe however you want to call it the
multiverse
that there's a channel that opens up of
a complete
surrender to the indescribable
perfection of
flow that occurs you naturally end up
being of the utmost highest morality
in ethics in the outward expression
yeah of that and so that sort of
understanding has been more and more
one of the core drives of the perennial
wisdom that are trying to
enter into more and more of
modernity in a way that helps them
solve many of the ethical and moral
quandaries
that exist again it's just these egoic
levels
the sugar cube that's this contracted
separate entity
is just holding on so separate so
fear-based so conspicuous consumption
greed based
and that it's just not recognizing it's
not dissolving yet
fully into that oneness into that
infinitude
into that shared being you know the
pupil in itself
is the shared eye of god and the iris is
the unique
coloration of that expression of it
and so the more that we sort of land our
hearts and our beings and our essence
in that knowing in that surrender
the more everything else just woo way
effortlessly unfolds
to the absolute highest so
so indescribable
and that's why at the top of that's why
at the top
of the the map of consciousness what do
you see with pure consciousness you see
ineffability it's ineffable
i remember when i studied with david
hawkins i went to sedona
and he began his lecture today we're
going to talk about
that which can't be talked about exactly
and everyone cracks up laughing
that's it the eternal the eternal dao
that can be named is not the eternal dao
yeah
it's just this this perennial wisdom
that's
continuously talked about from all these
different faces and paths
hawkins was in fact one of the best
humorous he was top-level humorist yeah
yeah exactly he knew how to
bring that into the equation it was so
perfect
and i walked out of there feeling i've
just
elevated i'm not the same person being
in his presence
exactly i was like i'm i'm altered it
just
brought me right up yeah now i want to
give another practical tip
on this whole thing let's do it is when
when you find someone's angry at you
or you know that's that's the thing that
trips us down in
into that lower state when we get into
reactive because someone's angry at us
and we naturally have this ego reacting
back
what i find is if i can go into a state
of love and compassion amen
and just beam that out their negativity
it doesn't get into me and it dissolves
and it dissolves from them
yeah give an example of that i was um
dropping my daughter off school at
school
and i was finding anyway
i was getting frustrated because the
woman in front of me i said why don't
you just move up a little i can get out
so she wouldn't move up so i back up my
car and
apparently i hit the truck behind me not
hard enough to dent it but just kind of
tap it or whatever
and then i zoomed out of that parking
space the woman behind me is in a big
dodge ram and she comes after me in
traffic and you could see i could see it
on her face she's raging mad
so i said oh i better pull over and so
she pulls up alongside of me she says
you
you know you you tap you hit my car and
i go
and so i thought oh i could get angry
back but what i did is i
i dropped into this love and compassion
and beamed it out and i said to her
oh my god i'm so sorry she says you
gotta not drive so fast you got to be
more careful i said
wow you're so right thank you so much
i really i i've you know apologize
and i'm gonna take your advice you
really you know
just basically gave her acceptance
and no fight back and so
i said okay and then she says okay um
so you go ahead and you have a good day
now and i said i thank you so much i
will
you too and it was like from the time
where she's going to pull a gun out and
shoot me
she's wishing me to have a great day
exactly and i just i find that so
helpful because we
so easily get into this reactive mind
especially
in the day and age we're in just when
people come at you with anger
relax breathe and project
love and compassion and their negativity
like you said it gets dissolved
and then you also are shielded so it's
not bringing you down
yeah and smiling at them and and you
know there's times where i say oh
let me understand what's going on with
you so you know i apologize if i did
something wrong it wasn't my intention
and just being able to
to be at a state where you're in that
higher level of consciousness
and that's what hawkins is talking about
is when you're up in those higher levels
my mentor les brown said this to me said
if you can't bring
other people up don't let them bring you
down
you know it's not your responsibility
but when you resonate at those high
levels
they often just rise right up and that's
what i find invariably happens
so here's here's the way that that i see
this
on the absolute highest
is an indescribable surrender to
the non-dual tune to the non-dual song
to the non-dual flow
yeah on another layer of it
we can say that there is a
a suffering that is
being eradicated and moving towards a
well-being and a prosperity in abundance
and within that exists what you describe
which is this recognizing the
egoic sugar cube that is
contracted and is creating a
negativity and you in a state
as you become more and more
self-realized as you pierce the veil as
you
have the well of honey of peace and
bliss 24 7 you're
just emanating out that's why it's
called enlightenment you're emanating
out the light
that state inevitably dissolves the
egoic sugar cubes
in the others that are bringing in
a negativity inward and so
the the entirety of
the situation is described in
all of these the nature of realities
described in all of these different
faces up the mountain which then
aim to help
people on their journeys to pierce the
veil and self-realize
themselves that's why when people like
you with the kinesiology institute i
mean i don't
you probably gave a dozen examples
throughout the conversation you might
have given 15 examples you gave a lot of
examples
those are all different faces different
strategies
to the same one end which is well-being
and in many ways that's what tony
robbins does with his events he's all
these different events that he does
across planet
the date with destiny unleash power
within there's all these different
events that he does
all these different interviews that we
do
all about describing
the different faces to the one truth of
just
peace bliss perfection yeah
indescribable now-ness and just being
here
with that and naturally that creates
the channel of the outward expression
which is your uniqueness
and this has been more and more the
common
perennial wisdom that's being revealed
that we're remembering
and it's just that's home that is home
we are home you know around us we are
walking
each other home we are just piercing the
veil and recognizing this
is home and that we become more and more
remembered to the true nature of our
being and we even this is probably a
good moment to wrap also with the beauty
of your harmonica and of the beauty of
the mute
of the music right music as alan watts
talked about music
it forces you to surrender into the flow
of the now and to the perfection of the
now
you can't be truly tapped into the music
while thinking about the past or the
future
you have to be present in order to be
fully engaged into the
harmonic or whatever instrument or even
the symbol just
dancing and stretching and just
releasing
and expanding this that that forces you
into the now
it forces you yeah in yeah yeah we
say in kinesiology that sound is really
the
the highest level of healing because it
affects
every body it affects the physical body
it affects the
emotional body the mental body the
spiritual body
and all the fields the chakras in fact
you can
balance the chakras with specific
frequencies
or vibrations like certain notes and so
yeah and while i was driving over here
today i was listening to the classical
station
and in fact there's a technique where
you can put classical music
on a specific acupressure point it's
called cv4
it's uh basically uh just below the
halfway point between your uh
belly button and in the pubic bone and
you can take a a little speaker like
even your earbud oh
so cool and you could put a adagio kind
of
like classical music like uh say like
pachelbel's canon
or box uh air on the g string and you
could put that
on that acupressure point and it deeply
soothes and heals all these aspects of
your body
that's such a good piece of wisdom too
yeah the actual speaker itself and move
it to
c4 it's cv conception vessel
four it's an acupressure point in the
future you touch your
uh umbilicus the the the navel and you
touch
uh the top of your pubic bone it's about
halfway between the two of those
and you don't have to listen to it you
don't have to hear the sound i was doing
that one time where
i was very stressed and uh so when i
wake up in the morning
i would put the the classical clock
uh radio on that point and just hold it
there for a couple minutes and it's like
god i feel so much better now
i know so sound actually has
uh in music a powerful effect on our
healing in fact i teach that in my
fundamentals course
how you can muscle test music and in
there when i play the classical music
people are really strong and something
that's weakened will be strengthened
yeah where if i listen to say like
gangsta rap exactly
it will weaken people exactly totally
and unfortunately
a lot of the music today is very
uh hard on our system in creating energy
blockage
but you you can choose choose things
that bring you energy and
and like you mentioned moving to music
and dancing
and expressing that's the you know the
last cheetah flow
and yeah this would be great if while
we have john playing the harmonica
that we surrender into
that now-ness okay the indescribable
perfection
okay i'm so excited for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
okay that was so nice thanks for letting
me do that
that was so nice i wonder
if we can play that's so so nice
and i love how the harmonica is so
mobile
and it just comes with you wherever you
go and you flip it out and it's so loud
i love that
i'm curious if
i'm getting this perfect position where
the sunlight the sun that's setting is
shining through the
people of the door and it's changing
colors from red to orange to yellow to
green to blue to purple it's so majestic
okay
oof wow just these simple things
and just briefly and that's why you know
terence mckenna when he was
on his way out after he was diagnosed
that he found eternity and infinity and
peace and bliss
and even the simple blade of grass or
the ant crawling
on the ground which is what the child
like essence
is before the like around 18 months or
so the child is just so
deeply like infinite and then all this
permanence everything with permanence
kicks in and
stuff like that i wonder if we can with
the harmonica it would be nice if
we can play where
if we take just the just the dbs the
decibels of what you're doing and if we
have that
and then if i come in and i kind of
rhythmically come in with some audio
let's see what we can do
levels of consciousness
we work our way
naturally
[Music]
from force to power
from the ego to the enlightenment
love for light consciousness
[Music]
that was still nice thank you you're
welcome thank you
i love that it's so childlike it's so
playful
it's just spontaneous and that's what is
the flow
yeah that's what is it john mcguire
thank you so much for coming on the
program it's been such a delight to
share and and just be be at one with you
likewise likewise
the kinesiology institute has so many
great offerings for people you gave like
15
different of these just like you know
this is going to be me now they're just
going to be like this
and like this and like this and all
these different tests
so i really hope that people can
leverage those very
simple different faces that you've shown
as well as
all of the there's a three day program
that's available on kinesiology
three-day class that gives you a lot
more
and we also have my book that's coming
out soon and i'm
writing a book on muscle testing a lot
of these little practical tips
and how you can use it to enhance your
health and
basically tap into your innate
intelligence in all aspects of your life
so i'm making that a digital copy
available to anyone
that wants to you can tell them how to
to go to support at
kinesiologyinstitute.com
exactly and request uh uh to say i'd
like the the muscle testing book
yes and uh as we get it out here shortly
we'll be able to
send them a digital copy of that
beautiful beautiful there's so
much in the all the instructions to this
are in the bio
so you can find all of the instructions
to request a digital copy of the muscle
testing book to access innate
intelligence support kinesiology
institute.com is where you'll send that
email
again all that info is in the bio
kinesiology institute.com links there
and also john's linkedin profile is down
there as well if you'd like to go and
connect with him
and thank you for
watching greatly appreciate you all
thank you so much
we would love to hear how you feel in
the comments below let us know
we'd love to also hear how the takeaways
are going
for everyone let us know how that's
going
and like the video subscribe if you
haven't
and share the video with people that you
know would find it interesting to learn
more about kinesiology and consciousness
and what john was sharing with us today
and that is all
pierce the veil self-realize surrender
to the
indescribable perfection i love you so
much
be well thank you for tuning in thank
you john
you're welcome thank you for thank you
having me here to
share all these gems that i can it's
been our honor thank you
all right you're the the
aroma of your flower has been
so nice thank you thank you